[Musique]
j'ai vécu en inde pendant trois ans je
me suis expatrié avec ma nouvelle
compagne ou une nouvelle aventure
j est survenu avec d'excellents moments
de vie et deux enfants nés à pune dans
la huitième ville du pays avec ses 5
millions d'habitants l'inde est un pays
extraordinaire et j'ai été profondément
touché notamment sur le handicap
en occident nous avons l'art de cacher
les personnes handicapées alors je sais
pas vous mais moi je croise que très
rarement des fauteuils roulants ou des
personnes en situation de handicap
un peu comme si la société et s'arranger
pour nous cacher tout ça en vivant et en
inde
c'est une autre lumière qui venait à moi
le handicap de tout genre étaient dans
la rue au quotidien alors je vais vous
le raconter avec légèreté et des mots
d'enfants aux feux rouges
on croise des hommes bossu marchands
comme quasimodo ou en allant au marché
des zones seront posées sur des skate
board fait de palettes de recyclage et
de roulements à bille ou bien encore un
homme sans bras dans ce train à bombay
il avait autour du cou une pochette uem
exactement la même que celle
qu'utilisent les enfants quand ils
prennent l'avion seul pour m carte
d'embarquement et passeport ce qui m'a
interpellé le plus ce n'est pas
l'absence de membres des personnes que
j'ai rencontrées
c'est leur capacité à s'adapter avec peu
de choses et leur sourire vraiment
surprenant
juan nouvelle calédonie je croise un
autre sourire celui d'une jeune
calédonienne qui a reçu d'une
association métropolitaine une prothèse
demain imprimé en 3d je préfère dire un
appareillage ludique
elle s'appelle mitsouko elle a perdu l
usage des doigts d'une main suite un
accident domestique
je m'intéresse de près à son histoire et
à l'impression 3d
très rapidement j'ai eu l'idée de
réaliser moi aussi des mains et les bras
pour des gens qui en ont besoin
alors pourquoi pas suivre l'exemple de
cette association basée à paris et de
refaire un petit peu le même modèle en
nouvelle calédonie ce réseau de maker de
fabricants est présent aujourd'hui dans
plus de 80 pays
je découvre ce qu'est la genesis
principale raison pour laquelle ces
appareillages sont fabriqués la genesis
est une malformation congénitale
elle représente en france métropolitaine
entre 300 et 350 nouveaux nés tous les
ans alors on trouve des mains avec des
petits doigts avec quelques doigts ou
tout simplement des simples bouts
d'avant-bras les prothèses existe depuis
longtemps plus on trouve des avancées
techniques et plus elle coûte cher de
plusieurs milliers d'euros à plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros en fonction
des technologies et lorsqu'elle
s'adresse à des enfants en pleine
croissance
elles deviennent rapidement obsolète
on estime à 12 à 18 mois d'utilisation
après elles deviennent trop petit
c'est là que l'impression 3d intervient
alors on dirait effectivement que cette
technologie a été fait pour ça bien sûr
pour fabriquer une main en impression 3d
il faut du temps mais reste que le coût
final est totalement marginal par
rapport aux prothèses existantes
on est à quelques dizaines d'euros
je dirais quelques milliers de francs
pacifique alors il faut se lancer et
pour créer une association il faut être
au minimum 3 j'organise un apéro
j'invite mes jeunes voisins je
représente le projet est pour le coup il
y adhèrent et c'est là que l' aventure
commence nous créons l'association
enamel ncsoft pacifique
j'en suis le président et je vous cache
pas que je suis ravi de la nouvelle
tournure que ça prend avec un peu plus
d'un an d'existence la plus jeune de
l'équipe
à 22 ans et le moins jeune 51
nous sommes à ce jour une dizaine
d'autres voisins sont venus rejoindre
l'association et pas que pour les apéros
alors on s'est mis rapidement au travail
très vite une question se pose combien
existe-t-il de cada genesi en nouvelle
calédonie et dans le pacifique sud
là encore on n'a pas réussi à avoir de
chiffres
bref quoi qu'il en soit avant d'aider
tout le monde
il fallait bien commencer par un premier
cas notre premier émerveillement remonte
il ya plus d'un an une amie de la
famille d'un petit garçon nous contacter
via notre site internet
ce petit garçon habite l'île de lifou il
est atteint d'une agénésie de la main
droite
quelques échanges avec le pape à une
série de photos les mesures et nous
réalisons la pièce principale que nous
expédions la paume de main un skype
permettra de valider la dimension et
nous lançons la fabrication complète
voilà nous sommes à la veille de la
remise officielle
découvrez mayol dix ans c'est la
première fois que l'on teste un
appareillage que venons de réaliser avec
nos petites mains en quelques secondes
on comprendre on comprend que le schéma
corporel de cet enfant allait changer
alors je vous cache pas les émotions et
notre fierté
certains enfants se sont rencontrés et
notre miss enamel est en charge de
offrir les appareillages alors comme les
nouvelles vont vite les choses se sont
accélérées et nous avons reçu d'autres
demandes d'un enfant de quatre mois
jusqu'à des adolescents jouent aval à 6
ans il fait partie d'une autre île de
l'archipel calédonien
il a également une double agénésie dans
son cas la demande était de fabriquer un
appareillage qui pourrait lui faciliter
l'apprentissage de l'écriture
on a rencontré les parents ainsi que le
corps médical
on a donc modéliser sa main en 3d avec
un scanner celle avec laquelle il écrit
déjà le travail de notre bénévole
ingénieur mécanique de profession a
était d'isoler les dimensions de la main
ensuite il faut modéliser les données
pour créer une coque à sa taille il ya
un logiciel de conception 3d
une fois le fichier créé on a imprimé
les pièces on a réalisé cinq prototypes
la pièce finale a été livré en juin
dernier accompagné d'une ergothérapeute
joue aval a rapidement trouvé ses
marques et à la grande surprise de sa
maîtresse
il écrivait pour la première fois les
mots en lettres attachées
alors au tout début de la vente de
laventure joue à vannes avait dessiné sa
main en couleurs passées les difficultés
techniques et maintenant que nous avons
un retour d'utilisation nous allons lui
en fabriquer une à sa demande de
personnalisation et quand il rebondit en
iran fera une un petit peu plus grande
et peut-être avec d'autres couleurs
ces appareillages simple
technologiquement ne sont pas que low
cost le fait d'avoir une main ou un bras
avec des couleurs peut aussi changer le
regard du handicap à travers et des
autres enfants et on découvre une
nouvelle facette celle de super héros
nous avons offert l'année dernière à
alessandro ce petit nouméens de quatre
ans une main fans de super-héros il
voulait une main comme iron man son
frère jumeau emilio qui n'a pas
d'handicap lui est fan de captain
america
alors nous les avons fabriqué un
bouclier est comme ça il y avait pas de
jaloux deux personnages marvel comics
man haïti six ans nous avons fait une
belle rencontre lorsque nous sommes
allés le voir à papeete sur le premier
skype est que la polynésie nous avions
remarqué que l'amplitude de son poignet
n'était pas suffisante pour actionner
une main donc nous avons choisi de
fabriquer un bras ainsi ils pouvaient
prendre les objets plus facilement
c'est ce que nous supposions et ça
marche il a choisi la couleur blanc pour
le bras et son papa a rajouté des
tatouages polynésiens d'evine et y une
jolie jeune fille de bora bora
alors nous lui avons fabriqué cet
appareillage couleur vanille suite à sa
demande elle évite assis le regard un
peu trop pesant quand elle va à la
grande ville à papeete
jusqu'il ya quelques semaines l utiliser
un bout de paréo pour cacher sa petite
main elle a accepté cet appareillage
comme un accessoire de mode
en proposant de personnaliser les
appareillages aux enfants et aux
adolescents
il participe au projet et se sont
investis et pour le coup ils ont chacun
un modèle unique
on peut tout adapter la forme la couleur
j'ai oublié de vous dire pour la main
d'iron man on a eu une remarque du
receveur parce que il manquait dans la
main le fameux laser dans la paume de
main alors j'ai dit qu'on ne lui ferai
la prochaine fois
la voix de cette technologie sourds
également aux adultes nous avons remis
il ya quelques jours à tâter ce pêcheur
lysiens 2 appareillage complet pour
qu'il retrouve plus d'autonomie
alors nous travaillons déjà sur la
version 2 où nous avons scanné les
avant-bras cette semaine l'idée de
modéliser les coques pour un meilleur
maintien afin qu'ils aient une meilleure
préhension des objets ces appareillages
notamment lorsqu'ils sont proposées aux
enfants s'inscrivent dans
l'apprentissage des futurs prothèse
qu'ils auront il ya plus de chances que
le taux de réussite d'utilisation des
prothèses soient supérieurs qu'avec
celui des adultes qui n'est aujourd'hui
que de 35 pour soi mais pour le moment
les appareillages que nous fabriquons ne
coûte pas un bras
alors personnellement j'ai la chance
d'avoir quatre beaux enfants
ils ont tous leurs dix doigts alors
pourquoi je mets autant d'énergie dans
tout ça le handicap ne me concerne pas
directement
certes pourtant il me touche
les sourires de ces enfants me touche
profondément alors toute l'équipe et moi
même
à notre niveau nous sommes tellement
fiers de contribuer au changement du
regard sur le handicap et surtout si
heureux de recevoir des sourires merci
[Applaudissements]